هذا هو احترام السوق من
الرئيس بايدن وهو يخفض الأعلام هنا
في البيت الأبيض إلى نصف الموظفين وفي
جميع المباني الفيدرالية
للأيام العديدة القادمة حتى دفن الملكة
إليزابيث وهذا ما يفعله البيت الأبيض
يأتي بعد فترة وجيزة من
إصدار الرئيس بايدن  بيانه الخاص
حول وفاتها قائلاً إنها كانت أكثر
من مجرد ملك ، قال إنها حددت
حقبة بالطبع التقى بها جيك لأول مرة
في عام 1982 عندما كان مجرد عضو في مجلس الشيوخ
رآها آخر مرة كرئيسة الصيف الماضي
عندما استضافت الرئيس بايدن و
السيدة الأولى جو بايدن لشرب شاي خاص
قال إنه كان لديهم اجتماع طويل
جدًا وأنها كانت كريمة
جدًا وتحدثت عن الاجتماع الذي عقدوه
وماذا طلبت منه بالطبع
وقالت إنها ذكّرته بجدته
وكان ذلك  اجتماع بالطبع جيك
الذي التقى به العديد من رؤساء الولايات المتحدة الآخرين
مع كل رئيس أمريكي منذ
هاري ترومان باستثناء LBJ ،
لقد رأيت العديد من هؤلاء الرؤساء
يشيدون بـ  o اليوم الرئيس
أوباما الرئيس ترامب الرئيس بوش
كما أدلى بيانا أنه من بين
أعز ذكرياته كرئيس
كان يحتسي الشاي مع الملكة وكلابها
قال في بيانه يتحدث
عنه والسيدة الأولى لورا بوش
ومدى تقديرهم لوقتها.